课程导读 大家好，欢迎回来透过AI播客学英文。
今天我们读的不是播客访谈，而是一份很有分量的课程讲稿——斯坦福的《生成式 AI 经济学》（Economics of Generative AI）第一讲。
讲师 Apoorva 是投资公司 Altimeter 的负责人，他曾在 Palantir 带过工程团队，后来转向投资。
这门课的第一堂，他就抛出了全课程最大的一个问题： Where's the money in AI?
（AI 的钱在哪里？
） Apoorva 用一张"倒三角"图表，讲透了整个 AI 生态的价值分布——为什么利润高度集中在底层的半导体（NVIDIA 毛利约 百分之七十五），而上层的 AI 应用反而最难赚钱；
为什么 AI 应用不像传统软件那样"边际成本趋零"，而必须烧掉 GPU；
以及 ChatGPT 十亿用户为什么每人每年只贡献 十美元、广告会不会成为新的解锁点。
词汇很专业但表达很口语，我们一起来逐段精读。
英文原文与讲解 开场点题：我们都在纠结的那个问题
And the biggest question that we've all been wrestling with—where's the money in AI?
而那个我们所有人都在苦苦纠结的最大问题——AI 的钱在哪里？
wrestle with（与……搏斗、苦苦思考）是本期第一个要重点学习的动词短语。
wrestle 本义是"摔跤、扭打"，wrestle with a problem 就是"和某个难题缠斗"，非常形象地表达"被一个问题困扰、反复思考"。
这句用破折号引出核心问题：where's the money in AI?
（AI 的钱在哪里？
）——这是整门课的中心议题。
money 在这里指"利润、赚钱的机会"，而不是字面的"钱"。
搭建算力：五层蛋糕与巨额资本支出
We are investing so much into the CapEx.
We're investing so much into building these data centers.
It's a 5-layer cake, as Jensen calls it.
Energy, chips, power, interconnects, memory—all that to give you a data center.
我们在投入巨额的资本支出。
我们投入巨资建设这些数据中心。
正如 Jensen 所说，这是一块五层蛋糕——能源、芯片、算力、互联、内存，所有这些加在一起，才构成一个数据中心。
CapEx（capital expenditure 资本支出）是投资术语，指企业用于购买、维护长期资产（如厂房设备）的大额支出。
AI 时代的巨额 CapEx，主要花在建设 data centers（数据中心） 上。
这里有个可爱的比喻：a 五-layer cake（一块五层蛋糕）——NVIDIA 的 CEO Jensen Huang（黄仁勋）把数据中心的构成比作一层层叠起来的蛋糕。
interconnects（互联）和 memory（内存）都是算力堆叠的组成部分。
注意 Jensen 指的正是 AI 芯片教父黄仁勋。
为什么 AI 生态是"倒三角
What is going on here is actually probably the biggest question in generative AI right now.
And to make an analog of the biggest technology revolutions that I have seen—internet 25 years ago, mobile 20 years ago, cloud, probably the most recent one, 10 years ago—the cloud ecosystem looks dramatically different than the AI ecosystem.
这里发生的事情，实际上是当下生成式 AI 中最大的问题。
为了类比我所见过的最大的技术革命——二十五年前的互联网、二十年前的移动互联网、以及大约 十年前的云计算——云生态系统与 AI 生态系统的形态截然不同。
make an analog of（与……做类比）是这里的关键表达，analog（类比）也可以写作 analogue。
Apoorva 用过去三次技术革命（互联网、移动、云）做参照，指出一个反常现象：云生态的图表是底部大、顶部小的"正三角"，而 AI 生态却正好反过来。
dramatically different（截然不同）中，dramatically（戏剧性地、大幅地）是强调差异程度的好副词。
学生的三种猜测，都指向真相
Is it because it's still early in the upside for AI?
… Or maybe because NVIDIA has a monopoly, so they can charge whatever.
… is it the cloud sectors seem to be able to leverage the hardware to generate revenue and AI haven't really got there yet?
是因为 AI 的上行空间还处于早期阶段吗？
……还是因为 NVIDIA 有垄断地位，所以可以随意定价？
……是不是云服务商能利用硬件来产生收益，而 AI 还没真正达到那个阶段？
这里连续出现了几个值得记的表达： the upside for AI——upside（上行空间、潜在好处）是投资高频词，常指"上涨潜力和积极的一面"。
has a monopoly（拥有垄断地位）——monopoly 指"垄断"，形容一家独大、可任意定价。
leverage the hardware to generate revenue（利用硬件产生收益）——leverage 作动词是"利用、发挥杠杆作用"，在商务英语里极常用。
学生的三种猜测——"太早了""NVIDIA 垄断""AI 还没把硬件变成收益"——其实都指向了真相，Apoorva 在后面逐一回应了它们。
软件吞噬世界，但 AI 不是那种经济
We know how software ate the world.
As Marc Andreessen said, software ate the world because I could build software, and I could distribute it to millions of people.
And the marginal cost of running that software was close to 0.
These software businesses ran at 80%—some even at 90%—gross margins.
我们知道软件如何吞噬了世界。
正如 Marc Andreessen 所说，软件吞噬世界，是因为我可以开发软件，而且能把它分发给数百万人，而运行该软件的边际成本接近于 零。
这些软件业务的毛利率高达 百分之八十，有些甚至达到 百分之九十。
software ate the world（软件吞噬了世界）是硅谷名言，出自 a16z 创始人 Marc Andreessen。
这句话的精髓在 marginal cost（边际成本）——每多服务一个用户的额外成本。
传统软件把一份拷贝分发数百万次，marginal cost was close to 零（边际成本几乎为零），所以能拥有 八十–百分之九十 的 gross margins（毛利率）。
gross margin 是"毛利率"——收入减去成本、再除以收入。
这是理解 AI 与传统软件经济差异的钥匙。
关键转折：AI 的增量用户并不免费
That is not the case with this new economic model of AI.
The incremental user of an AI application is not free.
It's not marginally free.
It's actually quite a bit more expensive to have AI users, because it turns out you've got to burn those GPUs.
但 AI 的这种新经济模式并非如此。
AI 应用的增量用户并不是免费的。
这可不是边际免费。
实际上，AI 用户的成本要高得多，因为事实证明你得烧掉那些 GPU。
这是全篇最重要的一个转折，也是理解"钱在哪里"的核心。
that is not the case（情况并非如此）是地道表达，用来否定前文。
incremental user（增量用户）中，incremental（增量的、边际的）是关键——每多一个用户的额外成本。
Apoorva 用了一个强烈的口语短语：you've got to burn those GPUs（你得烧掉那些 GPU）——burn 这里夸张地指"消耗、烧钱"，因为每次用户提问都要调用昂贵的显卡算力。
It's not marginally free 直译"并非边际免费"，是对传统软件"边际成本趋零"的漂亮回应。
周期错配：像铺设铁路一样建算力
And that's what makes the lower half of this triangle somewhat cyclical.
You go through phases of CapEx cycles.
Think of it as like laying down the railroads.
Eight years from breaking ground, eight years from first CapEx investment cycle, Amazon shifted fully to AWS.
而这正是倒三角的下半部分具有某种周期性的原因。
你会经历一轮轮的资本支出周期。
可以把它想象成铺设铁路。
从破土动工算起八年，从第一轮资本支出投资周期算起也是八年，亚马逊才全面转向 AWS。
Apoorva 提出了一个重要的"周期错配"观点：你建半导体和数据中心，是按 五–六年的周期来规划；
而应用的收入却是"当下"的。
他用了 laying down the railroads（铺设铁路） 这个经典类比——先把路修好，后面的经济才能跑起来。
cyclical（周期性的）是经济术语。
breaking ground（破土动工）是固定表达。
他举 AWS 的例子：二零零四 年起步、二零一零 年迎来 Netflix 这个首位客户、二零一二 年亚马逊全面自用——整整八年才走完一个周期。
基础设施层最致命的问题：你是功能还是平台？
The inference layer is the most competitive part of the whole ecosystem.
There's a lot of startups that are doing really well.
But you've also got the hyperscalers who want to have a dominant say in that layer.
So honestly, the jury's still out.
And the biggest question there is, are you a feature or a platform?
推理层是整个生态系统中竞争最激烈的部分。
有很多创业公司做得相当不错，但你也看到超大规模云服务商想在这一层拥有主导话语权。
说实话，结果还悬而未决。
那里最大的问题是：你是一个功能，还是一个平台？
这里出现了几个重要概念： inference layer（推理层）——模型训练好之后，实际给用户跑任务的环节叫"推理"（inference），这个中间层是竞争最激烈的战场。
hyperscalers（超大规模云服务商）——指 AWS、GCP、Azure 这类巨头。
the jury's still out（结果尚无定论）——jury 是"陪审团"，这个习语指"事情还没有最终定论"，非常地道。
are you a feature or a platform?
（你是功能还是平台？
）——这是全篇最值得记住的一个问题。
feature（功能）是依附于别人平台的小插件；
platform（平台）是别人依附于你的底座。
Apoorva 提醒那些 Infra 层的新公司：如果你做的事"为什么不是 AWS 的一部分"，那你可能只是一个 feature。
价值如何聚集：两年新增收入的 百分之七十五 进了半导体
I did the same exercise that I did about two years ago.
And what it looked like two years ago was this thing on the left, where the ecosystem was obviously a lot smaller—about five times smaller.
Shockingly, the shape of it hasn't changed much.
This is despite heroic growth.
If you look at the revenue that was added, about $350 billion or so of revenue added, a good 75% of it just went straight to Semis.
我重复了两年前做过的同样的测算。
两年前，生态系统明显小得多——大约只有现在五分之一。
令人震惊的是，它的形态几乎没有变化。
尽管增长十分惊人。
看看新增的收入：大约增加了 三千五百亿美元，而其中足有 百分之七十五 直接流向了半导体层。
value is accruing（价值正在聚集）是这段的主题。
accrue（聚集、累积）是金融英语里很重要的动词。
Apoorva 用数据说话：两年间整个生态新增约 三千五百亿美元 收入，但 百分之七十五 直接进了 Semis（半导体层）——尽管应用层增长了十倍，却"没有造成多大影响"（didn't make that big of a dent）。
make a dent（留下凹痕、产生影响）是地道比喻。
heroic growth（惊人的增长）中，heroic 本义"英雄的"，口语化地表示"极大规模、史诗般的"。
Semis 是 semiconductors（半导体） 的简称。
各层最赚钱的部分：NVIDIA 的毛利
The most profitable part of the stack is the Semis layer by a long shot.
NVIDIA's data center revenues are on a gross margin of about 75%.
Whereas, I estimate some of the Application Layer revenues to be somewhere between, depending on who you ask, 0% and 30%.
And so the gap is quite wide.
整个技术栈里利润最丰厚的是半导体层，遥遥领先。
NVIDIA 的数据中心收入毛利率约为 百分之七十五。
而我估计应用层的部分收入，则根据你问谁，大概在 百分之零 到 百分之三十 之间。
所以这个差距相当大。
by a long shot（差得远、远远地）是英语中常见的强调短语，常出现在否定句（not by a long shot 远非如此），这里用在肯定句中表示"遥遥领先"。
the stack（技术栈）指从底层到顶层的完整技术分层。
The gap is quite wide（差距相当大）——NVIDIA 的 百分之七十五 毛利对比应用层的 零–百分之三十，这就是"钱"集中在哪里的直接答案：越往底层、越靠近芯片，利润越厚；
越往应用层，越难赚钱。
消费 AI 的变现困境：十亿用户，十美元一年
The rough economics of consumer applications—Alphabet has about 4 billion users.
They monetize them at about $100 a user a year.
Meta's got about 3.
5 billion users that monetize at about $70 a user a year.
The leading AI provider ChatGPT has got about a billion users that are monetized at about $10 a user a year.
And so the question is, how do we get the billion up to 4 billion?
消费者应用的大致经济账是这样的——Alphabet 大约有 四十亿用户，每人每年带来约 一百美元的变现。
Meta 大约有 三十五亿用户，每人每年约 七十美元。
而领先的 AI 服务商 ChatGPT 大约有 十亿用户，每人每年只变现约 十美元。
所以问题在于：如何把这 十亿用户做到 四十亿？
monetize（变现）是这部分的绝对核心词——指"把用户和流量转化为收入"。
这段数据对比极其震撼： Alphabet：四十亿用户 × 一百美元 / 人·年 Meta：三十五亿用户 × 七十美元 / 人·年 ChatGPT：十亿用户 × 十美元 / 人·年 The rough economics（粗略的经济账）中 rough（粗略的、大致的）用于数据估计。
Apoorva 提出的两个问题都很尖锐：一是怎么把 十亿用户做到 四十亿（知识工作是不是所有人的工作？
），二是怎么把每人每年 十美元提升到 一百美元。
knowledge work（知识工作）在这里是关键——ChatGPT 是"主动劳动"的地方，你必须去问问题，而不是像刷抖音那样被动获得快感（dopamine fix，多巴胺快感）。
广告还是订阅？
AI 的下一个大解锁
I'm not sure subscription is the answer.
I suspect we'll have to go into ads.
I suspect the ads that ChatGPT will be able to serve—or Claude will be able to serve—will have a lot better pricing because they will understand your intent, that you will be logged in, very good attribution, a lot more trust.
I think that will be the other big headline this year.
And you heard it here first.
It'll be a big deal.
我不确定订阅是答案。
我怀疑我们不得不转向广告。
我推测 ChatGPT 或 Claude 将来能投放的广告会有好得多的定价，因为它们能理解你的意图、你会登录、有非常好的归因、还有更多信任。
我认为那将是今年的另一个重磅头条。
你们最先在这儿听到。
它会是一件大事。
这是 Apoorva 关于 AI 变现最核心的判断：订阅（subscription）可能不够，广告（ads）才是让每人每年收入从 十美元 走向 一百美元 的路径。
他给出 AI 广告会更有价值的四个理由：understand your intent（理解你的意图）、you will be logged in（你会保持登录）、very good attribution（非常好的归因）、a lot more trust（更多信任）。
attribution（归因）是广告行业术语，指"把转化归因到具体广告的能力"。
a big headline（重磅新闻）、It'll be a big deal（这事会很了不起） 都是口语强调。
这句 you heard it here first（你先在这里听到）很生动，暗示这是独家观点。
历史镜鉴：手机的屏幕也能塞进广告
10 years ago, at the Facebook IPO, there was a lot of short reports on Facebook because people said, hey, these ads worked on a computer, they're not going to work on a phone.
Why?
Because there's no space on a phone.
Shocker, we found the space on a phone.
The same thing's going on right now—I don't want to be interrupted by advertisements.
But I am optimistic that we will find it.
And I think that's going to be a big unlock, a big unlock for this economic model.
十年前 Facebook 上市时，市场上有很多看空报告，因为人们说：这些广告在电脑上有效，但在手机上不会有效。
为什么？
因为手机上没地方放广告。
真没想到，我们竟然在手机上找到了地方。
同样的事情正在发生——我不想被广告打断。
但我乐观地认为我们会找到办法。
而我认为那将是巨大的解锁，是这个经济模型的巨大解锁。
这是一个很有说服力的历史类比。
short reports（看空报告）——short 在这里是"做空"，short reports 指认为股价会跌的研报。
当年人们说 there's no space on a phone（手机上没地方放广告），结果市场 found the space（找到了空间）。
Shocker（真没想到）是口语感叹。
Apoorva 用这个类比说明：今天大家觉得"AI 对话不该被广告打扰"，未来很可能也会像手机广告一样"被找到空间"。
最后那个 a big unlock（巨大的解锁）——unlock 作名词，指"开启某扇门的钥匙、解锁价值的关键"，是近年投资圈很流行的词。
主题升华 这期斯坦福课程讲稿，其实回答的就是题目里那个直白的问题——AI 的钱在哪里？
Apoorva 给的答案很清晰，也多少有些出人意料：钱在"底部"，不在"顶部"。
至少目前，AI 生态的价值高度聚集在最底层的半导体——NVIDIA 一家就吃掉了大量利润，毛利高达 百分之七十五；
而大家眼里最热闹的应用层，收入虽在十倍增长，却迟迟没能"砸出一个坑"。
整个形态像一张倒立的三角，跟过去云生态的"正三角"恰好相反。
但 Apoorva 更想讲的是规律——这张图不会永远倒着。
云生态花了大约十年才翻过来，AI 也许要更久，因为"把底层地基做好太难了"。
他反复提醒我们用一个更长远的眼光看这件事：建算力像铺铁路，有周期、有错配，但路修好了，经济迟早会跑起来。
历史上每一次技术革命（互联网、移动、云）都经历过类似的阶段：底层先吃到利润，应用层的价值随后才慢慢浮现。
而在他抛出的众多问题里，我觉得最值得回味的，一个是 "are you a feature or a platform?
"（你是功能还是平台？
），另一个是关于变现的乐观判断——AI 的广告会因为它更懂你的意图、更懂归因而比传统广告值钱得多。
当我们觉得"对话里不该有广告"时，别忘了十年前人们也觉得"手机上没地方放广告"。
那句最值得记住的判断，我们再回味一遍： The biggest question that we've all been wrestling with—where's the money in AI?
我们所有人都在苦苦纠结的最大问题——AI 的钱在哪里？
愿你在研究或踏入这个行业时，也带着这个问题去看每一张财报、每一个商业模式：钱在哪个层？
这个层会翻转吗？
我又该站在三角的哪一边？
好，这期关于 AI 经济学的精读，我们就先讲到这。